[Applaudissements]
3 millions opération jupons sur arte
will est d'ailleurs un ne manquez pas la
chronique de camille combal parce qu'il
a trouvé des images de touche pas à mon
poste façon art et vous allez voir c'est
camille combal qui a trouvé ça et ne le
manquez pas oui valérie benhaddou 1 mais
pour répondre à gilles gilles c'est
normal que ça reste également une
émission de télévision et dans une
émission de télévision il faut des
candidats qui fasse que les gens restent
et notamment des gens qu'on a envie de
pas aimé et celui ce personnage là c'est
un personnage qui juge la cuisine quand
même s'il est mauvais et oui ma faim
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qui reprendra sa vie locale et personnel
est sur le plateau des parodies